[Music]
now I know it feels like all hope is
lost but together we can stop battles I
think we'll pass just kid we're it
ready I'm Peter by the way dr. strange
oh you're using your made-up names then
I am spider-man don't forget this might
be dangerous so let's put on our mean
faces
what happened
my wipers get it off
how's this dude still alive he is not a
dude
Nura dude this this is a man my hat's
off muscular man it's like as the
muscles are made of cotati metal fibers
stop massaging his muscles
wake him up
[Music]
who are you guys
in time he will know what it's like to
lose thread it run from it the end is
near
we got one advantage
we have a dance once
so that's what we use
I think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good Wow today I would don't
fight for oneness
we fight for all of that
put that thing away now I don't want to
tell you again
hey everybody there's a whole bunch of
marble stuff that just dropped between
this in Deadpool but we finally got a
high quality version of Thor trying to
recruit the guardians of the galaxy in
more context for what's happening during
that scene in a couple of new cool shots
of Doctor Strange Iron Man with his new
bleeding-edge armor activating a really
cool sword so let's break it down if
you're finding me for the first time
there is an Infinity Gauntlet replica
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter that it'd just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so I just
did a video talking about how they've
always been trading the Thanos and the
Gamora voiceovers and then they just
released a high quality clip with Thor
doing the voice-over for the trailer so
maybe we'll get versions of that with
the other a-list Avengers like with Iron
Man opening one of the trailers but
we've talked about some of the comedy
with this Thor guardians of the galaxy
pairing like it goes from really WTF and
serious when he's on the Asgardian ship
with Thanos and all those people end up
dying and you immediately swing back to
comedy with this face plant on the
mulatto like oh my god what happened
here cut to wipers wipers and I do like
the way the screen writers wrote Drax
for this movie because he can be kind of
hard to nail like his comedy either is
really really funny or it just doesn't
land at all he's not a dude you're a
dude he's a man a muscular man the funny
thing that Chris Hemsworth was calling
this team the other day was as guardians
of the galaxy when they released all
those posters just because his poster
features the guardians of the galaxy
so the different posters give you a
pretty good idea for what the different
teams are for most of the film but then
I obviously by the end they all start to
converge because I think that Avengers
for the whole ideas is that they're
together like you have all these
different vignettes you have Thor with
the guardians you have Captain America
his Secret Avengers and they all slowly
make their way to Akhanda by the third
act of the film even though most of the
team Ironman footage we've seen is
either of him at the sanctum with this
battle or him on the planet Titan
fighting in this big battle here I think
that's just because they want to show
you the big WTF action scenes like look
at all the crazy stuff we're doing even
though it's not necessarily in narrative
order but if you are wondering the way
they colored these posters isn't
necessarily an easter egg for the gems
that they possess or the gems that
they're going after or trying to protect
because like you have spider-man iron
man dr. strange Wang here but you have
the red of the reality gem so dr.
strange has the time gem it's not
necessarily accurate to the gems that
they possess during the film the way
that Marvel's marketing this is kind of
unreliable when it comes to where the
Infinity stones are or where they go in
Dennis's gauntlet if you look back to
the promos and the test footage from way
back a couple of years ago like that
Thanos Infinity Gauntlet shot that
Marvel released a couple years ago that
everybody freaks out about the gems are
in different locations than they are in
all the brand-new Thanos promo art just
because I think they decided to change
the order so they want him to like
slowly add gems in a relatively logical
order but because they want the story to
progress in a certain way he goes after
certain gems before other gems and I
think they don't want it to look weird
if he just grabs gems from all over the
fist and assembles it that way like one
at a time just like stacking them one
right next to the other looks a little
bit better so that required that they
changed the sockets which most of the
gems go in and they've already changed
the color to the infinity gems for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a long time
ago anyway so if there are a bunch of
you out there that are slowly starting
to read the Infinity Saga and all these
classic stories that the movies are
based on don't worry if it's confusing
about where the gems are and which
people have them Marvel changes all
kinds of stuff like that when they get
to the movie it will totally make sense
don't worry the other funny thing about
this I'm actually gonna have to track
this across all the other trailers and
whatever other footage they end up
dropping is is that teenage Groot or
adolescent Groot is still playing his
video game when Thor is on the table
here like you look down in the corner
here this is why you need high quality
versions of these clips sometimes they
release them and they're like jenkees
cell phone quality so it's always a bit
of a hunt to try and find the original
high quality versions of these but I
just love the idea that he's playing
like his Nintendo switch over here
whatever the space equivalent of a
Nintendo switches you can guess about
what game he's playing but I'm sure
there's an easter egg in here too but
remember in guardians to how Peter quill
had repurposed that classic techno
football game as a detector he might
have done the same thing for Groot
although this is kind of the low-hanging
comedy fruit of the film I'm just
interested to see what he does when
everything gets really WTF and crazy
because most of the
I'm he's with Thor they're forging his
new Stormbreaker weapon and I think the
reason why we haven't seen Thor in any
of these other trailer shots is one
because it does take a little while for
him to forge his new weapon like they
actually had to travel there then he has
to learn how to smith it he has to
bargain with the dwarves then he can
come back and help the Avengers out but
by that time I think well I've already
gotten to crazytown with this big
Wakanda battle and we'll have already
had the Titan battle but it's possible
if he does show up somewhere during one
of these he would show up on Titan but
remember like I said by the very end of
the film I think they'll have all
converged like Thor will eventually make
his way back to earth and the rest of
the Avengers but even though I didn't
talk about it when Black Panther came
out there were a lot of people that were
looking at his throne there were a lot
of runes that were etched on it in the
wakandan language people were like wait
a minute those look kind of like
Asgardian ruins is this some sort of
like space-based crossover going on here
what's going on so when it comes to
Black Panther this crazy pyramid
underground of the vibranium mines that
we didn't really actually get that much
of during the film I think all this is
just ancient Wakanda and this isn't like
them borrowing from Asgardian mythology
or anything like that
although you have to remember the way
they tease life on earth during the
Black Panther opening credits sequence
is that the vibranium Mound crashed
earth in the early days of man like just
did the dawn of man they founded their
borders around the vibranium Mound and
defended it and then obviously the rest
of humanity evolved over time to what
you see today but then you travel a
little further north you remember the
ancient history pre-credit sequence of
that first Thor film where Odin is
telling the story of how he protected
the realms of man he comes down to help
out in that big battle against the frost
giants the Asgardians would have known
about the vibranium so I'm interested to
see if there's any kind of recognition
on Thor's face but let me know in the
comments like given all the history of
the earth that we know via the Thor
movies how much do you think that Thor
knows about what's going on in Wakanda
so for those of you asking which is
stronger hooroo metal or vibranium it
really depends on whether or not the ARU
metal has been enchanted but the really
big news is is that a main cast member
left the arrow TV show I'll do a video
for that episode next they release test
footage of the Deadpool TV series that
just got canceled so I'll do video for
that too but that might not post till
Saturday morning so don't worry there's
a whole bunch of Marvel stuff coming up
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Master Li please private message
me so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post new
Marvel click here for that other big
trailer that just posted and click here
for the new trailer for Westworld season
2 because that's getting ready to start
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]